day two of cooking my friend's favorite
comfort Foods kimchi so good Joelle said
that this is a staple meal in any Korean
household and the recipe that she sent
me was written by fellow tasty producer
Jasmine pack but with some tips from
Joel's Grandma who always calls her to
remind her of specific cooking tips like
not to boil the cup for too long because
it'll make the soup slimy kimchi chicken
is a quick and easy meal that can make
any fridge leftovers taste delicious and
Joelle said that it's a basic meal that
many Korean kids cook for themselves
after leaving their parents for the
first time and really encapsulates a lot
of the korean-american young adult
experience which is an experience I can
definitely relate to and that's